keeping lunch i do it myself it seems to
be very very good keeping breakfast does
not seem to be good at all right so
there's study after study after study
showing decreased uh lifespan for people
just keep practicing well that well this
doctor longer i'm in deep [ __ ] then if
that's the case because i don't think
i've eaten breakfast in 25 years
[Music]
the garyvee audio experience
vayner nation it is great to be back on
the garyvee audio experience uh as we
said earlier in the year a lot less
interviews but ones that are more
meaningful to me around subject matters
that i'm interested in people i'm
interested in events that i'm interested
in and today will be no different uh dr
longo is with us i'm going to allow
walter to introduce himself in full
detail
and we're going to talk about something
that i've been doing my whole life
long before it became something that i
think is on many more people's radars
and we're going gonna poke and prod
around the history of it the current of
it uh entrepreneurship and and many
other things that uh i want to get to in
this episode but let's get into uh the
intro part uh dr longo how are you my
friend
good good how are you i'm well why don't
you
take the floor for two three four
minutes and tell everybody who you are
full
full pledge give us some context
okay
well i'm a biochemist by training
trained at ucla uh also a neurobiologist
by training
and
i'm now a professor of bio gerontology
so studying aging basically
and uh uh malsa the director of the
longevity institute at usc
and then i i run a program on cancer a
molecular oncology in milan italy um and
that's where we do all the most of the
cancer work that we
were carrying out
and yeah my interest has always been
since i was 19 years old aging um
well i used to be a musician then i i
was uh so uh enthusiastic about aging
and and uh
you know
excited about this world and i was just
surprised back then that nobody that
everybody was not interested in this
and and
i have to say in the last uh
30 years everything changed back then
aging was viewed as a crazy uh science
and you know we were asked at ucla why
would you work on aging and now
everything has changed but yeah so
that's all i've been doing uh since then
biochemistry then genetics of aging uh
was involved in the discovery some of
the the key genes in the the regular
lifespan including the torah as cis
kinase
pathway in aging regulation
and then eventually we
i was a student of roy walford roy back
then was the guru of longevity and
nutrition i was a famous pathologist at
ucla that
was my mentor for a number of years and
uh
and since then we've been working on
nutrition in parallel with the genetics
of aging working on nutrition and
aging and then eventually uh used uh
defined this fasting mimicking diet as a
way
to keep all the benefit of what roy
walford was working on which was called
calorie restriction
so what happens in people if you just
severely restore calories all the time
so i didn't like that but and so
eventually we switched from that you
know a continuous restriction of
calories which works it's fantastic in
some sense but bad in other senses to a
periodic fascinating diet is it possible
that you can do something only three
four times a year for five days and you
get all these effects positive effects
so calorie restriction
but not the negative what's right
dr longo why
at such a young age did you fall in love
or get passionate about
aging why why did that happen
i don't know but i was a music major
and i just kept thinking about aging for
some reason it i i expect when you're
you were you scared to die were you van
were you was it vein oriented like you
didn't want to look older was it vanity
or was it fear or something altogether
different
no i mean not all that i mean of course
i was 19 years old so i think it might
have been you know
when my grandfather died that was five
years old and i was actually in the room
when he died you know so i just think
that connection you know when you're
five being in a room and just having
this sense he died of a heart attack
no he died of a cancer that he wasn't
treating you know and he was fairly
young 75 76 or something like that so i
just thought i wasn't affected by i at
least i didn't think i was affected by
it back then right that was very well
and i looked almost like i was in charge
of the situation as a five-year-old but
you know i think that just stayed in my
head you know life is not permanent and
uh
and so maybe i should work on that right
rather than
the house that i can think of you know
i understand so
something very interesting with me is
um
i grew up i was born in the former
soviet union
um i came to america when i was three
and
you know my my parents worked hard my
mom worked all day
you know raising family my dad worked
all the time and specifically my dad he
wouldn't eat breakfast or lunch
and he would always eat a lot of
calories at dinner you know and that's
how i got kind of brought up and that's
the track i had and then
somewhere along the line
in my mid-20s
you know i started to gain weight for
the first time in my life
and in my late 20s
i was gaining enough weight that i was
like wait a minute this sucks
but i had no interest in working out or
eating properly
and so what ended up happening was it
was so easy for me
to go from
waking up until 7 or 8 p.m without
eating my body
like it's 1 38 p.m right now i haven't
eaten breakfast or lunch and and and
that is my natural state
and i you know my friends are all so
obsessed with lunch and i always you
know they always when people meet me and
get to spend time close to me they're
always fascinated by the no lunch thing
and but it's always been my whole life i
worked in the store and there was no
time for lunch that was when we'd get a
rush in the store and
so
when i was in my late 20s
and i wanted to lose weight it was easy
for me to just fight at night i used to
always joke with my mom it's like i can
do young kapoor once a week you know
like i could fast
you know it wasn't easy because you're
so hungry by night when your body
structured the way i was doing it
but then later in my late 30s and early
40s the last you know seven eight years
i i really got serious about health and
wellness i work out all the time i work
on stretching a lot of different things
and one of the go-to's for me when i
when i'm struggling a little bit with
food management has been fasting and i
really enjoy it like very much enjoy it
um
[Music]
what you know
what
is it for most people because i've been
talking to a lot of people
about it because it's obviously become
this is something you've been doing for
your whole career
in some shape or form obviously as you
know you're with prolonged you're very
in it fasting has become much more top
of mind
for a lot of people over the last half
decade
yeah
what what is it in people's minds when
they first so i've been talking a lot
more about it that's why i wanted you on
the show what is it that scares people
so much like it's unbelievable to me how
many times i'm saying to my friends you
know my friend will be like man i want
to start getting my
act together like have you thought about
fasting that seems to them as no way i
can't do that i can't not eat in a day
why why is that such a
like
visceral reaction from so many people
that i've come across
yeah well essentially food is like drugs
right so there's a clear addiction for
good reason not for bad reason for good
reason right well we should eat uh i
mean
for the very majority of the history of
humans but also the primates and
everything else before that uh food you
eat as much as you can get right and um
and because eventually the winter is
gonna come and you're not gonna have
anything and so if you didn't overeat uh
during the summer when there was a lot
of fruits and honey and nuts you're
going to die right that's that's how
strong that signal is eat eat eat and
get fat by the way right and there was
this the what saved you right getting
fat as fat as possible
was was save people during the winter
yeah so that's why you can't uh
sort of
instinct-wise you cannot tell somebody
stop eating um and and then again you
know
it's very important in your show to
point out that fasting i always say
doesn't mean anything right so so fast
is like eating you know is eating good
for you well yeah some of it is and and
some quantities and some other foods are
not and some other quantities are not
right so
for example skipping breakfast skipping
lunch i do it myself it seems to be very
very good
skipping breakfast breakfast does not
seem to be good at all right so there's
style you have to study after study
showing
decreased uh lifespan for people to skip
breakfast right so then you could say
well that well this doctor longer i'm in
deep [ __ ] then if that's the case
because i don't think i've eaten
breakfast in 25 years i'm gonna get my
acne together yeah it may be that on you
it does at a course sometimes maybe you
come from a family that always did it
then of course of course but i think
that's you know real quick i apologize
it's an important point i as people
become obsessed with health and wellness
i keep reminding all the people in my
life i'm like yes that is a study yes
that is a trend yes that is science but
don't forget you better do individual
work on your own blood work on your own
like you have to get a sense of you just
like anything there are common themes
but some people have different
structures correct yeah correct but but
you're still going to vegas right so
you're you're still
betting against the numbers right so
correct of skipping breakfast for
example you know you're looking at about
10 studies pretty consistently showing
reduced lifespan in those that skip
breakfast now is it breakfast is it that
people just keep breakfast have bad
behaviors in general and they're more
excited it's hard to know what surprise
right though is if it's so good to skip
breakfast why doesn't that counter
balance the bad
behavior right why why don't we see at
least neutral effects right you skip
breakfast it's very good for you
why isn't it making your bad behavior
neutral
and that's what's what's concerning
right that that we don't see a neutral
effect we see a negative effects of or
so they suggest for example could it be
that the ketone bodies
we're doing mouse studies right now and
we were surprised to see that the
highest ketone bodies of all wear in the
western diet right so the western diet
also causes ketogenesis you know these
byproducts of fat that people always
talk about as a positive thing but
they're very high in the western diet
right so could it be that by having
ketone bodies high all the time you put
a strain on your heart or you know they
may be
fat accumulation etc we don't know
so uh so probably best to have breakfast
and skip lunch i think lunch is what
i've been doing for 20 years uh and
that's a great way to uh regulate that
you know not over not get the ketone
body is too high
but control the weight
and uh and i think it's got a central
role in in helping
against diseases dr one of one of the
reasons i really wanted you also is i've
been thinking a lot about science
professors
professionals entering the
entrepreneurial world
so there's a lot of people who are
listening to my show
who are in academia
who are in the medical field who are in
incredibly
high virtue
careers
who i think
are worried at times to jump into
entrepreneurship because they're taking
their talents their knowledge
this you know thing they put on a
pedestal and they're bringing it to the
business world and i'm very empathetic
to them i they believe they are
compromising
you know selling out uh they're worried
about the judgment of their fellow
uh you know partners in academia or
finance or uh education or other things
you obviously have a company
you know you do these things
from a scientific
academic background was that a challenge
for you to make the leap into
entrepreneurship
did you consider it was it something on
your radar earlier in your life and you
didn't want to do it because you felt
like it could hurt the science hurt the
mission it's not the right thing to do
when you're trying to really help people
i think this is a profound conversation
and since you're going through it with
prolonged i thought you could be a great
source of inspiration for some of the
people that are on the fence how did you
go through your journey of
being in this from a medical academy
standpoint to making a jump into
entrepreneurship
you know i actually i think the other
way around right so i will argue that i
felt that if i wasn't going to do it it
wasn't going to happen and that's
probably true right so we were working
on cancer and fasting making diet and
diabetes and fasting making diet and i
just thought for the sake of getting it
out there to patients uh if i don't go
find the clinicians if i don't sit down
with them
and start the trials but also say hey
there's a product because otherwise what
are you gonna do the clinical trial with
right uh it was uh nearly impossible i
think without a company at least back
then 15 years ago
to start this operation now we have over
30 clinical trials running and
and i think
you know the company sponsors some of
them and lots of others are sponsored by
the us government by foundations by the
universities themselves right so i just
felt kind of like this argument was also
made about doctors right they showed a
doctor or a group of people in a
hospital and it turns out there's
probably who you want to ha own a
hospital right you want a
doctor to own the hospital
because they're going to be much more
aligned with the patient when it comes
down to a decision a doctor is always
going to go
with
protect the patient right
businessman might not right somebody
selling drugs might not right so
in my case i'm always going to think
there is no way i'm compromising you
know the safety and the health of the
patient even if it's a billion dollars
to be made right but i think a
businessman would not hesitate and uh i
mean you know within the the domains of
the law or the
of course uh i think most businessmen
will say well if it's legal i'll do it i
would say no it could be legal it's
going to hurt the patient you're not
going to do this
of course of course
yeah i actually you know what's funny i
actually think
the best businessmen and women
think about the value exchange the most
i i even think if it's going to hurt
somebody emotionally it's a bad thing so
you know i think that's a very powerful
thing what are the biggest
misconceptions in the modern fasting
conversation because you know what
happens now
bad business people who genuinely just
care about money and could give a [ __ ]
about humans or patients they see a
trend and then they start exploiting it
what bad information or like help us
here like what's some of the stuff that
undereducated influencers or
entrepreneurs or even doc pseudo
like what are we seeing from like bad
information like what's a thing that you
see people believing is true but isn't
give us a little cheat sheet of things
to watch out for if you're on your
journey to potentially get a little bit
into fasting because if everyone's
listening like again i know a lot of
people
genuinely
are looking to be healthier and happier
and all those things that i you know
there's a famous clip in my content of
like what do i think about health and
wellness when it comes to business and i
reply to the kid as i'm walking on the
floor of a of a convention i reply well
if you're dead you're out of business
and it like really got very popular so
you know i like having people like dr
longo on occasionally one because i
thought that little part about
entrepreneurship in the scheme of
academia and health and well is
important but then number two
you know i like i like to keep everybody
who's listening to the show around
longer so they can achieve all their
hopes and dreams and i really think for
a lot of you who've never tried it that
it is
going to be fasting that's going to be
the breakthrough on you shedding 15
pounds feeling healthier feeling better
so i really want to inspire some people
to at least try it may not be right for
you but at least try
dr longo what are some of the watch out
for this right now because everyone's
talking about it in
fasting one of them we already mentioned
right for example and probably the most
popular oil you can do 16 hours and you
know and i love the work that sachin
panda and others have done on that but
the 16 hours of fasting and just keeping
breakfast is clearly associated with
lots of problems you know not just to
reduce
life but also gallstone formation
and um so so i will say that
we need to go from
the word fasting
uh to
what do we know that works and there are
many studies showing that it works and
it's unlikely to cause any problems and
uh
and also what is going to be the effect
of this on lifespan and health span and
not just what's going to happen next
three months are you going to lose some
weight so you could lose a lot of weight
in a lot of ways right but you most
cases you regain it back and as as you
go through let's say 10 or more weight
loss and 10 or more weight regain
that also is associated with a shorter
lifespan right so it's better to do
nothing than to do these yo-yo
interventions so
i think the misconception is very
wide
and and so there are very few things
that i think consistently work for
example
and don't have any negative studies
associated with it for example 12 hours
a day of fasting i always say i've never
seen a negative study on 12 hours of
fasting 12 hours of feeding so it's time
to stick to eating is not you don't get
the benefit the quick benefits that you
get with 14 or 16 hours
but you may get long-term uh i mean much
easier to to not to stay with it and
then you know much more likely to get
you to a long lifespan
and then you know of course the other
one i'm a fan of is you know uh fasting
mimicking diet let's say three or four
times a year uh again a safety record is
is very very good i think over probably
a million people now i have done it and
we haven't heard uh back from uh i mean
the side effects have been really
spectacularly low
and uh yeah so i think that um
and i think the fascinating underlines
the
the
the importance of having things
clinically tested as so we have the fda
for drugs so we have this incredible
process even look at what happened with
coffee right
i mean we still have people were dying
but everybody say wait you know we
cannot uh
get things out there just because they
may save lives because they're probably
gonna hurt more people than they save so
let's wait until the approval it went
very quickly but it still required
approval now in the fasting world and
all of that there is no approval at all
it's just you wake up in the morning you
hear something and it's like okay i'm
going to start doing it well that's
probably going to hurt you in the long
run not help you but hurt you so
focus on the things that have lots of
clinical trials on and uh and and so
yeah 12 hours of fasting and the fasting
making diet three or four times a year
uh i think those are very good and then
you know i i wrote a book called the
longevity diet and all of it
by the way all the all
my shares of the company are going to go
to charity right so that's another way
of uh
and i don't take a penny in consulting
from the company so i really financially
don't make in the world company
you're the company we're talking about
programs we're talking about problem and
then a little neutral
one more time because i think it's going
to be a pretty big business um
congratulations so you're saying
all of the profits they are coming your
way you're you're donating 100 of my
shares and a hundred percent of the of
the um
consulting or whatever goes already to
my
my foundation the great cures uh
foundation and and even my book
royalties go to my foundation right so i
really only make whatever i make at the
university as a professor and nothing
else right so
was that important to you because you
felt that it wouldn't compromise your
professor medical work yes because i got
attacked by lots of journalists right
then i got attacked on this years ago
already and i could sense that yes that
fear or not they were going to attack me
oh he's trying to exploit uh the the
research to make money and so i say you
know what uh i'm just gonna
let me do this do this
dr
like before we get out of here like
what's your intuition like if everything
goes well this may happen after you're
not on earth like what's your intuition
as as humans become more educated with
the power of
what i would call
food scheduling right like like just
being more
uh educated on how this all works what
do you think it kind of looks like 50
100 years from now if this is
universally understood and executed yeah
i think it's gonna
i like to think it's good what's going
to happen next 10 years i think what's
going to happen you're going to have two
groups in the world right you're going
to have whatever eight billion people
that don't don't listen to anything they
do whatever they want and then we're
gonna have maybe half a billion to a
billion people they say you know what
i'm gonna follow the scientists the
science you know what i call the
multi-pillar approach you know clinical
studies epidemiological studies you put
it together and you get a pre particular
picture in fact there was a study that
came out a couple weeks ago on plus
medicine showing if you start even at
age 60 if you start something very close
to what i described as the longevity
diet
you
are associated your life is gonna have
eight or nine extra years right so
starting right now so i think that yeah
we we're gonna have this two population
one following everything and living
maybe an extra 20 years uh and uh and
everybody and everybody
else improvising and uh maybe on average
living
20 years less
eventually i think you know we're gonna
get better and better you know 100 years
from now then i think it's a different
world you know it's a different world
and and i think uh unfortunately or
fortunately we're gonna see a lot of
engineering bioengineering robotics say
and uh uh playing playing a part you
know so now we can make artificial
hearts artificial you know
pancreas uh
releasing insulin etc etc so you know
that and it should be it should be so um
if it's gonna be much more a part of uh
human life you know gonna be part human
impart
machine and and you know we already are
right so we already are and lots of
people are walking around with pumps
uh diabetes type one so it's just a
reality and the engineers are are so
good that moving forward it's gonna take
a long time right so i think now
nutrition is by far the investment for
the next 20 or 30 years eventually
slowly i think that the technology is
going to take over
and uh
dr longo if if i asked you if somebody's
20 years old right now
yeah what's your guess your educated
guess on what their life expectancy yeah
so that the study showed that if you
started the longevity diet or something
like it and
at 20 that would be 13 extra years of
life expectancy right so so then uh
you're looking at that 20 year old
following everything maybe looking at
105 as an average lifespan which is
pretty remarkable right uh yeah so also
105 average following all the right
things uh uh with lots of people making
it 110 115
uh
yeah so that that's what i i think it's
uh the numbers are showing but it's got
to be a careful uh
consideration of all the things you do
probably working with some professionals
that help you get there
anything we didn't touch on as we get
out of here
uh yeah just very briefly the longevity
diet i think you know what came out of
that study was lots of legumes no red
meat
no processed meat
lots of nuts uh
lots of vegetables and
so those are the main things that came
out of the everyday
uh nutrition uh and fish was allowed but
that seemed to be
the best
animal source of proteins so some fish
and everything else coming from legumes
uh protein-wise so a diet that almost
nobody in the united states follows but
that it will make a tremendous
difference i think together with the
fmds and making people
live longer and healthier
but so many people don't want to give up
steak you know it's but
we published a study a few months ago
where we took mice and we put them in a
high calorie high protein really bad
western diet right and they became very
big you know and they live very short
yes and then we did exactly the same but
we gave them once a month the fasting
mimicking diet and it reversed
everything so they live normal life
perfect weight
so yeah so then i think uh if you don't
want to give up anything if somebody is
going to have a bad western diet then it
may have have to be as frequently as
once a month
the fasting making diet
so wait a minute real quick that's a
really interesting insight it is your
hypothesis that if you're a bad western
dieting
that if you fast for
on a certain regimen once a month that
there's
an offset there that is balancing so
we've shown this in now three clinical
trials right and there's a fourth one i
mean one we publish three are going to
be published in the next six months
right so very clearly uh the people that
start the worst you know the ones that
have high higher cholesterol higher
blood pressure higher fasting glucose
they're the ones that do the best after
the three cycles of the fasting making
diet so very clearly mice but also very
clear in in human trials that yes those
that have the worst diet
uh would uh could potentially uh and
we're not at all saying okay keep a bad
diet in fact i just said you know people
should switch to a longevity diet but
understanding that most people don't
want to do that or lots of people don't
want to do that then yes you might have
to go
uh to a fastly mimicking diet
as often as once a month but then i
think as that helps you
then you could go once every two months
once every three months so it could be
the beginning you have a bad diet and
then you do
the the fmd once a month and then
eventually maybe once every two or three
months it could be enough uh
to uh
to offset at least
lots of problems caused by your your bad
habits not just diet you know smoking
you know we didn't test that but i mean
that's what uh what we
speculate at least you know that
it could be a way to reverse bad habits
you know
cheers dr longo thank you for being on
the show